foreign
Professor we got another anonymous
question here this one's from Montana
I have an abundance of health
information bouncing around in my head I
have firsthand experience of what my
body body responds well to and what acts
like poison in my body I have acquired
knowledge and understanding on how and
why foods can heal or make me sick I
have access to recipes a kitchen full of
tools the money to fill my fridge with
nutritious healing food I've even paid
for Reliable food sensitivity tests and
while my GP has not been overly helpful
my naturopath has been together all of
this could have me in great condition
but I'm not
the littlest amount of milkshake gluten
or alcoholic beverage is so damaging to
my inflammation and blood sugar levels
that I get discouraged and so severely
symptomatic that I just end up eating
more of said food that's essentially
poison for my body and some warped
attempt to make me feel better
the physical pain is so severe that the
lesser of two evils has been for me to
use some alcohol in the evening to take
the edge off
THC isn't a good option for me and
opioids are something I'll avoid at all
cost
CBD doesn't really touch the pain but I
do use it sometimes
over the counter painkillers they're not
strong enough and actually make the
inflammation worse later for me
no amount of food prep
keeps me disciplined through the whole
day let alone a week
I ask myself and have really considered
that maybe this is a self-worth issue
that I have not been able to be more
like Joshua who's fiercely protective of
his health
I do seem to have some sugar addiction
symptoms
social pressure also affects me and I'm
not in a position to avoid many of the
scenarios that arise
how do I transcend these patterns when
all the information in the world doesn't
intervene
I ask myself what is missing if present
would make the difference
I keep coming back to discipline being
the thing that I need
but if that's the case how do I grow
that the pain is so severe that it's
hard to cope
I use distraction and busyness as a way
to force myself not to think about what
my body is feeling
I need to find a way out of this
experience
I'm spiraling
being approximately 40 pounds overweight
in pain and sick is literally killing me
and it's a slow miserable route to
travel towards death on
Ah that's so much compassion for you I
am
I I resonate with this so much and I'll
just say this to start discipline
doesn't work no at least not for what
you're trying to do discipline for a
short period of time might get something
done today you can have discipline to
Stave off the sugar for this meal but on
a long enough timeline whether it's
social pressures societal pressures
Temptation impulse something's going to
creep in that's going to kill your
discipline now there are two at least
two types of people in the world and Bex
and I have talked about this on on her
podcast how to love
um Bex is more of a moderator I'm more
of an Eliminator right and our caller
here it sounds like you would benefit
more from elimination you know one way
to look at that is feasting versus
fasting and for me is I can't I it's all
or nothing for me right and so at first
that seems really really restrictive my
diet to the average person is so hyper
restrictive they look at that and they
say oh my God I could never do that it
must take a lot of discipline wrong it
takes no discipline to maintain my
really strict autoimmune diet but the
reason that it takes no discipline is
because I've simply said I can't do
those other things it's not restrictive
you know what is restrictive really
being in crippling pain 24 hours a day
it's suffering throughout the day is so
much more restrictive than oh no I can't
eat that processed packaged food in fact
what I found is that my diet is so
restrictive that it's freeing because I
go to the grocery store I walk in there
and I say oh none of this is food
um
and why why do I say that well it has to
do with pain pain is a compass that
points us toward healing and I think the
caller's problem is actually she hasn't
suffered enough pain yet I know that
sounds
insensitive but it's the opposite I
understand the pain that you're in and
you're 98 of the way there and having
that last two percent of pain really
recognizing that the healing takes place
when you're fed up with the pain this is
enough I'm not willing to touch another
drop of alcohol I'm not willing to touch
anything that's inflammatory now for you
it could be different from what is
inflammatory for me yeah if I eat a
potato it feels like my ankles are
broken because of the autoimmune disease
that I have and so I just don't eat
potatoes it's not an option for me
because I know how painful that's going
to be is that restrictive no not nearly
as much as the pain is going to be
waking up in terrible crippling pain is
awful it's so restrictive that it's not
even an option for me I'm not compelled
by the potato I'm repelled by it because
I know how much pain it's going to bring
into my life what's interesting about
your pain is even though you experience
the amount of pain after that experience
that was sufficient for you to like get
it together
it's not the case that you experience
that Vivid pain in every moment where
perhaps the right decision making is
required right now you're not in that
pain but you're still going to make the
right choice what's going on there
herein lies the distinction between
knowledge of Truth and remembrance of
Truth knowledge of Truth is about having
the intellectual awareness of fact
remembrance of Truth is about finding
ways to maintain a sense of vividness
finding a way to hold on to that truth
in spite of the fact that my
circumstances and conditions are
sometimes going to make it easy for me
to forget C.S Lewis says faith is the
art of holding on to what you already
know to be true in spite of your
shifting moods that's the challenge of
life we know what we need to do to live
healthfully but we often forget it there
was this uh TV show one time where they
played like this Halloween prank where
they would walk people through this
morgue and through the cemetery and
these would all be people who claim to
not believe in ghosts and things like
that and so they walked them through the
more they'd be like are you afraid or no
like why would I be afraid I'm in a
morgue I'm in a cemetery but then at
night time the people had to do this
challenge where they had to walk through
the morgue and walk through the cemetery
and they played this spooky music and
everything when they were doing it and
people were freaking out and it's like
well what's going on intellectually
these people don't believe in ghosts and
in a sober moment it's so clear but when
you turn off the lights when it's dark
outside when you're playing spooky music
and you're walking through a morgue and
you've got all the horror movie
associations
what you know to be true kind of feels
untrue right and your non-belief and
ghosts starts to feel a little bit
questionable and that's what life
challenges do to us like we know what
that road leads to we know that we don't
want to go down that path but it feels
like maybe it'll feel good this time and
so one thing I'd recommend is
when you have those moments of pain find
a way to take some kind of snapshot of
it what works for you as a reminder of
the pain you feel when you do the things
that are unhealthy for you because in
those moments of Temptation the voice of
Temptation is going to show you a very
Vivid picture of the comfort and
pleasure that you feel and you need a
picture of the opposite that is more
compelling than that what is that
picture for you did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free